[Music]
[Music]
been noticing on Ali Ali Ali Ali sorry
so out of it today
they said they're gonna keep me at the
top of the list and that's good Ali if
you don't mind staying for another
couple of our trip immature
if anything goes wrong and if I'm not
well one thing we look for in insomniacs
is people who get sort of anxious about
the idea of sleeping itself and that
contributes to keeping you awake is
there anything in particular you're
feeling anxious about like why are you
even stressed don't make such a big deal
I'm sorry I don't want to know I it's
not my max you can't I know
okay I'd recommend trying not to put too
much pressure on yourself especially
fall asleep I just feel like I need a
night off you know you guys have fun
though okay okay I said yesterday you
want to start working out again
I live okay Ali I already told you I'm
completely happy for the answer you know
but this just sounds like a really good
opportunity for you you know you're not
supposed to drink coffee if you're
having sleep problems now this will help
you sleep if you really need to take
some sleeping pills or something
thank you so much thanks hey mind if I
join sorry I'm running late it took me
almost 20 minutes last night to fall
asleep
I just kept tossing and turning Jenna
thought she got your email
no I didn't send the email okay why did
you tell me that you know bringing it up
over and over when I keep telling you I
am perfectly happy with my career right
you lied to me I would have stopped
bringing it up if you told me the truth
about what you wanted I don't need
anything from you fine I guess I'll pay
for dinner what was that
are you that unhappy like is this that
nothing right now you haven't been
feeling good you haven't been sleeping
we've got a [ __ ] and shitty because of
that and I don't know how to react when
you don't let me in so what am I
supposed to do with that I don't know
it's been like that for a long time and
I don't know if it's just a thing we're
working through or if we're just
drifting apart what are you saying right
now I don't know I mean I think maybe we
should break up
[Music]
okay
[Music]
I'm gonna go
[Music]
you